i've quit shaving my legs but when you
sang
the hair on my legs grew an inch and a
half so
katy perry reveals why she stopped
shaving her legs
and katherine mcphee returns to her old
stomping grounds for a moving duet
[Music]
[Applause]
it all went down on sunday night's
episode of american idol
after contesting cassandra coleman's
performance during the top 24's all-star
duets and
solos round
yeah and katie who gave birth to her
daughter daisy dove bloom back in august
she had an um unusual way of
complimenting the 24 year old singer
uh voice is a spiritual experience
it is otherworldly angelic and as a new
mother
i don't have very much time so i've quit
shaving my legs
but when you sang the hair on my legs
grew an inch and a half
so full body chills
oh wow wow that was amazing yeah and
just in case you weren't buying it
fellow judge luke bryan did some fact
checking
luke was checking to make sure you were
telling the truth while you were talking
oh she literally has leg hair thank you
for the forensic report
but cassandra she wasn't the only
contestant to wow the judges
fan favorite willie spence grabbed their
attention in a big way during his
audition
and said his career goal was to win a
grammy in the next
five years in five years
what do you want it to look like in your
wildest dreams if nothing was standing
in your way
i just want my voice to reach the world
and just
share my gift hopefully winning a grammy
one day that's why i see myself in five
years
yeah and on sunday he proved it when he
joined american idol alum
catherine mcphee for a touching next
level rendition of andrea buchelli and
celine dion's 1999 classic
the prayer
[Music]
catherine was the runner-up during the
show's fifth season in 2006
and not only was she in awe of willie's
performance
he made the prayer of something that
andrea botelli said sound like something
that willie would say really
so we're the judges you do no wrong in
my
eyes i mean part of being a star is
making people fall in love with you man
i'm just in love with you
in our business you don't want to be a
singer
you want to be a stylist you have your
own
lane it's just mesmerizing to watch it
it was goosebumps central everywhere so
could cassandra or willy win the whole
thing this year
when it caught up with the judges in
2020
they dished on what it takes to go all
the way
it's mental gymnastics and it's really
like
it's the master class obstacle course in
a
crunch period amount of time i think you
know lionel said something the other day
you know
you can't let other talent
psych you out that's right you have to
be what you are
and what you are just because this
person may be
technically the best singer in all of
america i don't they may not have the
personality
that you have they don't have the x
factor so
control what you can control handle your
[Music]
business
you